Where I come from
we had to fight for a free press.
I was born and raised in a military dictatorship
with just one TV channel
and a few newspapers with official information.
But that dictator, Pinochet in Chile,
couldn’t handle the critical work of brave
journalists
who dared to ask the right questions at the
right time.
As a journalist I have walked through the
streets of many countries
and the problems are always the same:
poverty, social inequality,
lack of freedom of the press
and corruption.
One of our responsibilities as journalists
is
to face those in power,  those that make decisions for the
people.
Asking, demanding the truth,
for those who can’t or who are not allowed.
We can’t afford to stay silent
when it comes to the defense of human and
civil rights
of those that have decided
to put their trust in us.